Now and then I think of when they were together.
Like when you found a route that went from X to Y
All those paths, they went through A and B, which
isolates them from that whole subtree. It was a
bridge and it’s a bridge that now is severed.
You can try computing when a graph is all
connected. You put the neighbors on a list, the
open list. So when I tried to run a depth-first
search. And found that half the graph was in I
guess it means it makes the search that more
efficient.
But you didn’t have to cut the path. Drop that singular
connection, start a new component. Now each is in a
separate graph, so their reachable descendents have been
split in half. No it doesn’t change the time, big O or
the clustering coefficient in the social network.
I guess that I don’t need that though.
Now there’s just no pathway that can use two nodes
Now and then I think of all the times you chilled
me over. But had me believing it was always
something that I'd done. But I don’t wanna loop
again. Though my running time is. You said you’d
use efficient codes and you wouldn’t waste your
cycles finding pathways that can you to know
But you didn’t have to cut the path. Drop that
singular connection, start a new component. Now
each is in a separate graph, so their reachable
descendents have been split in half. No it doesn’t
change the time, big O or the clustering coefficient
in the social network. I guess that I don’t need that
though.
Now there’s just no pathway that can use two nodes
[No pathways]
That can use two nodes.
Now there’s just no pathway that can use two nodes
[No pathways]
That can use two nodes
Now there’s just no pathway that can use two nodes
[No pathways]
That can use two nodes
That can use two nodes.
[No pathways]